- On this episode, I tape the episode tape
I record the episode getting off the plane
from the super bowl.
How do you think it went?
(upbeat music)
- You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
'Sup, everybody?
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and you're watching
episode number 66
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
You might also be listening to it.
I need to stop saying watching,
I've been here for the
last couple episodes.
As you could tell, I just got off a plane.
My flight was cancelled yesterday from
Let's just tell the whole
story, the bottom line was
I said I wasn't even going
to watch the super bowl.
Some of you know that my business partner
in VaynerRSE my fund
is Steve Ross, the owner
of the Miami Dolphins
he invited me to the Super Bowl with him.
You know, the owner's
parties all that stuff
you know, I thought it would be good
for me to start getting used to it.
With what the future holds,
and so I suckered myself
made a humongous mistake, promised myself
I would never watch the
Patriots in a Super Bowl
in case they won.
Not only did that happen,
but I ended up being there
and then everybody knows
since the whole world
watched what unfolded.
So, you know, Staphon made,
tried to make me feel
a little bit better as I
just got here off the plane.
That, you know, at least you
got, you know he was funny
he was like, "At least you
got another prediction right."
So, you know, I don't know
if you can do the recall
but you might as well do a little editing
DRock I know it's a little later.
Let's go to the moment where I say that
I think that the Patriots are gonna win.
27-12 Patriots, this Sunday,
that is my firm prediction.
I equally do not want that to happen
but I did say on this show,
I wanted them to stick it in
my face and hit rock bottom.
It looks like they are trying to execute.
But they do cheat.
Yup, so rock bottom tastes delicious.
It's what I've got right now.
Let's go on to the show.
- [Voiceover] David asks, "I'm at the point
where I need to hire an office assistant.
Sales are great, but I don't
necessarily have the capital
to pull the trigger.
Any creative ideas on how to achieve this?"
- David, that is a great
question, and it's really fun
to be in the presence of DRock,
one of the people who
I think payed forward
and is going to feel the huge
dividend on the way back.
Meaning, I know a lot of
real hard-core watchers
and listeners.
I know that you DRock first
at a video for me for free.
Was that Clouds and Dirt?
That's epic, let's link that up.
And, you know, that led to a relationship
which lead to a full time gig.
And now, will be my heart and soul
as long as he'll have me
in my video's world, which, you know,
Super Bowl videos of the Jets winning.
Amazing, you never know DRock.
So, I think one of the things you can do
is use your social capital
to put out there that
you're looking for somebody
and that this how you can compensate.
Obviously, money is the accepted
compensation in our society
but I gotta tell you, like
I think that there's a day
and age with the internet
being a middle platform
where other things can be used.
And so, I don't know
So, obviously you just felt an
edit because DRock screwed up
kind of like Pete Carol
at the one yard line
by not double checking the card.
Because I'm not double checking the card,
or the card went weird on you.
Okay, well, you messed up.
- [DRock] (mumbling)
- Yeah.
- Right, let's get a
DRock messed up alert.
I wanna make sure, I
wanna double check this.
Just so you know, I do double check
so I want to see if it's pretty,
but it better really over the top to rock
the DRock messed up alert
it better be legit, 'cause it only happens
once every 66 episodes.
Does anybody think it's
interesting that it's episode 66
one more six, the devil, the
Patriots won, Belichick.
And so, anyway, going back
not sure where it got cut off
but just make sure you edit it
weird DRock everybody knows
that there was a mistake on your end.
I think that there's a lot of ways
to be able to barter out that service.
I would literally put on Craig's list
and on your social media, and e-mail blast
and take your ten closest
friends and have them blast
and say look, I'm looking for this,
this is what I can offer.
Maybe that's minimum wage,
plus I'll give you all my
services free for a year
or there's a million ways to hack.
I think that we in our modern
society across the globe
outside a very rural part pockets
in parts of the world that you know,
I'm not educated enough to know this.
We are really in a flat
out currency exchange game
and I'm a big believer
that over the next 50 years
because the internet shrinks the middle
but there will be an
opportunity as a matter of fact
I'm gonna make another
prediction, Staphon,
that there will be a major
platform in the next 15 years
that is a major top 50 start-up
that is infrastructure for us to trade.
Like, straight up like
Ebay, Craig's list, mobile
you know centric where it's just like,
you know I have this coat laying around
and someone's like, "Cool,
I'll mow your lawn."
Like just, there is so
much inefficiency and stuff
and services provided
I think you should go that
route maybe make a video
maybe take the momentum of this answer
go really do something
the other thing is to
really pound the streets
meaning just like know,
no rock unturned right,
just ask a lot of people
there is a lot of people out there
and I think in our
society not paying in cash
feels taking advantage
I think I've consistently
been on the offense in nuances
of like border exchange
I just think there's a
lot that can be done maybe
maybe you have a collection
of rare baseball cards
that somebody wants.
Or, you know you've 14
pairs of awesome Nikes
maybe you could've six.
You have assets around you,
your time, your services
a crap load of stuff in your house
trade that for what you need.
Or go with do your when
good enough of a name
to make a promise that hey I can pay this
but I promise you as soon as we get going
I'm gonna make you the full time person
I think the one thing that I promise you
that you need to make sure you do.
is a lot of people
promise and don't deliver
and I highly recommend you
don't make that promise
unless you feel like you can deliver
and the reason I make so many promises
I always say to myself,
even if I fail business wise
I'll go to my own bank
account and close the gap.
If you're willing to go to that level
and I don't know your
personal finances, but
anyway, barter, barter, barter.
Hey Gary Vaynerchuk this is
Colin AKA Dj Veaux here
and I've got one question for you
What is your advice for musicians looking
to establish themselves on Instagram?
I know you've talked
about it on Twitter before
but I love hear your thoughts
on this specific platform
Thanks, my man, keep up the great work.
I like this young hustler,
there's something about him.
I've seen this video before
I've seen him interact a little bit
there's something about this kid.
I'm just saying it now on the record
so I can be writer with
another prediction, Staphon
17 years from today
this kid is gonna have some juice.
You know, I don't know
up in the music world
but like I just can feel it.
Anyway take that and run with
it kid. It's good momentum.
You know, I think it's
15 second videos, right?
Like you just did, I'm
pumped that you made a video
and the answer is predicated
on the communication format.
I think for Musicians to
over index on Instagram
it's gonna have to be around the music
I think the 15 second video format works
I think using the right hash tags
is the way to be discovered
I think reaching out the other Instagram
influences in the space matters.
So, hitting people up
finding, you know, a ton
of Instagram people
are putting their e-mails in there.
Now a lot of those people
are getting compensated financially
and, you know, I've no
idea of your finances,
but I'm going to be prejudice
or assume that on the younger
side it's not unlimited.
But again, back to like this
maybe this is the theme of the show.
There's probably a ton
of Instagram hoochies
a muscle dudes, who've
huge, huge followings.
That you can hit up and say
look, I'll make you 15 second theme song
or something for your world
if you can give a little
love to me in return.
If I were you and man, am I pissed
that the internet wasn't around
when I was 14, 15, 16, 17, 18,19.
I mean it was around but,
normal people not straight up nerds
The internet itself, is
basically 20-years-old.
And I know there is some
nerd in the background
like, "Oh, actually 1959."
I know (bleep) but I mean
when normal people went on.
I really, really think that
I think that I would spent
just 17, 18 hours a day
hitting up people via
e-mail on Instagram accounts
going to explore, finding some people
that are popular hitting their accounts
seeing that they have
over 100,000 followers
and just pounding them
with e-mails saying hey
I make music, I'll make some music for you
I'm looking for exposure,
but just we very up front
don't try to trick them
like if we'll make a song
and something interesting can happen.
How many beverages does a man need?
- You asked me to get coffee.
- Oh okay, Mike got me coffee too.
Double fisted, what?
And so, you know that's
the route I would go
You need as much exposure as possible
You're in an Instagram community
get into the trenches.
A lot of those people
who look for money
they won't say yes, but I'm telling you
you'll get four yes's
for every 800 e-mails
and for lot of people listening
that's a lot of time for four yes's
but, the truth is what's
the alternative, losing?
- [Voiceover] Jaime asks,
"I have an Instagram niche account
is building followers pretty fast.
What do you think about
selling advertisement
like a 15 second commercial
to people wanting
to reach my audience?"
- Jaime, first of all I'm in love
with your Instagram account
super pumped for it, you know super niche
very Crush It! Like the
culmination of that for me
so, feels cool another prediction
global production that I drilled.
And so, oh, I'm just getting,
this is the worst day.
First of all, you've 585 followers,
so won't gonna be able to get
as much money as you
know a walk in the park
so, first I would focus
on next six to 12 months.
The answer's yes
I do think once every seven
jab, jab, jab, right hook!
You know once every seven Instagram videos
for you to make a commercial,
is super appropriate will work
and if you can make it more
of an entertainment commercial
like you staring in it think
1950's and '60s television
I know lot of you youngsters.
But the original commercials
are very integrated
even into the '70s.
Alpo I think it was,
you know, the dog food
was getting dogs to come on the set
of the The Today Show and eat the food.
You know, and so, you know
that, that's been around forever
and that's coming back, old is new
like Missy Elliot you see
all the kids on social media
being like, "Oh, Katy Perry
put this Missy Elliot on.
It's pretty intense to watch all this.
Kids need to get educated,
these 13-year-olds
I love though, I mean, I
believe it they're winning
they're right.
So, just wanted everybody to know that.
Anyway,
what's really interesting to me is that.
What I would do for you, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna drop, down flip
it and reverse it on you
and give you a different answer.
You need to basically
google volleyball blogs,
volleyball media, volleyball news
And you need to e-mail every single person
on the first 80 pages of results
and tell them what you are doing
and seeing if you can get
them to give you exposure.
You should absolutely be pounding
the volleyball community right now
all 917 influencers that
matter in volleyball
need to know who you are
and you need to be the one
that e-mails then and
says, "Yo, what's up?"
Period. Email every
volleyball manufacturer
and be like check out what I'm doing.
Guys, most of you were not taking it.
You have to understand what
I did with Wine Library TV
I took it.
I e-mailed everybody, everybody
that was wine blog in 2006
and said "Hey, I'm doing this."
And I get that not everybody is
as comfortable self-promoting.
And I love when my friends
from Europe are like,
"Oh, it's a very American thing."
And a lot of people who
watching are introverted
or don't have as much hustle.
Look, I'm a funny guy,
I'm very competitive
I was in super crazy networking events.
This weekend and like the
commissioner is there.
And Woody Johnson and you know
all these actors and actress and VIP's
and hall of famers and
I'm not going up to them.
Because I'm so competitive and ego like
I'm gonna make them come to me.
But there's a part of
that that's super wrong.
There they are and then I took way
that I took that a way
from myself little bit.
And I went and did 5 or 6 some of them.
Can't do it completely.
But like, you know,
taking those steps as well
so like for all my
extrovert, salesman stuff
I've my own spiel that like
prevents me from taking it.
But I'm telling you,
behind keyboard, e-mailing,
volleyballdaily.com and being like
"Hey, it's me. I'm doing this thing,
you should just check it out.
I love to do something."
Be smart, position it properly not like,
"Hey, look, I'm doing this
Instagram thing about volleyball.
You should write about it."
No, that's right hook. Jab!
Like, "Hey, it's me, I'm doing this thing
I love our community.
If there's anything I can
ever do for you let me know."
Jab.
So, take it.
Oh, India got excited, she said cool.
I wasn't done yet India.
Yeah.
It was a good one, right?
You want to write a
full-fledged, hard core,
we're gonna write a full hard core. Next.
- [Voiceover] Austin
asks, "What do you mean
when you focus on top line revenue?
Is it because you care
more about staying relevant
and having attention
because you can cash it
on that for more sales?"
- Austin, no I talk
about top line revenues,
the answer is no.
That's not what I am looking to do.
I'm looking to drive top line revenue.
I'm doing it in VaynerMedia right now.
I'm glad my financial people aren't here.
'Cause they'd be like, "I'm not
sure what you're up to, Gary
but it's super interesting."
So, here's what I am up to CFO's.
When you drive profit,
if you bring in expenses
like I have, when you
have more and more people.
You may not make as much money right away
because if you are making $12 million,
and it cost you $12 million
to run your business,
you make zero dollars.
And if the year before it cost you,
you know, did in 8 million in revenue,
but it only cost you $5.3 million
in expenses to drive it,
you made $2.7 in profits.
So, even though you are doing
a lot more business this year
you are not making as much money.
But that's also human
infrastructure and the learnings
and the people to be able to for you to do
not 14, but 40 million next year, got it?
Simple as that nothing else.
You just gotta make sure your expenses
don't over go your sales
because then you can't make payroll
and you go out of business
or you have bumps in the
road and things of that nature.
And I as an entrepreneur have had
a substantially good career over 20 years
of pushing the limit of how
much I can take expenses
and cash to be able to grow my business
and that is something that
I am always focused on.
I think it's super important,
I know how to do it
and it's the reason
that I know uniquely now
have a second business under my belt
where I have taken the business
from three to over $50 million
in revenue within a 5 year window.
That is unusual, that is not the norm,
and it talks to having a stomach
that wants to drive top line.
So, that's not for everybody,
and everybody has got to be
safe and wants to make payroll.
But a lot of you are not
moving your business faster
because of lack of
offense, lack of spending
18 hours a day e-mailing
800 people on Instagram
to know about your music stuff.
You are lacking offense on
e-mailing every single person
talking about volleyball in
the world on the internet
and saying "Hey here I am" and
you are lacking by not investing,
maybe you have the finances
for that office secretary,
who then will allow you
to be on the offense doing
other things, instead of
doing some damn paper work.
Boy, I tied that together like a champ.
- Hi Gary! It's Alesya from Alesyabags,
and I have one important question for you,
this year I've got a great bag coming out,
way higher quality than
anything that I've ever done,
but, they're more expensive too,
how do I work at that
to my current audience?
That's a good question,
you know the weird answer
is maybe you shouldn't.
If the price point of
your new bag is 300 bucks
and you've been selling 25 dollar bags,
you just might not want to
market to your current audiences,
because they can't maybe
afford to buy that bag.
Now maybe they can, like you know,
I buy 20 dollars or 500
dollars things in same category,
so, you know that's not whole
H&M like you know,
like the way fashion got so
interesting to me by the way,
little fun fact
but any way, I think that it
is very important for you to understand,
much they give advise
the prior two questions,
that you may have to go out,
and find a new audience,
and that's scary that
might not be the, look
I'm thinking right know as your watching,
I'm curious how you're watching,
leave in the comments, are
you watching like this?
or on the laptop, or, really curious
how you're consuming this. Do it.
But
the truth is you may have to
go out and find a new audience
and that's by putting yourself out there,
and engaging with others.
I think influences on Instagram
are massively important, so
I think you can get away with
giving away some of these bags,
to some of those influencers,
and getting them on the
cheap at my opinion.
So I would definitely
go down the instagarm,
influencer path.
I think if you give away 5 to 10 bags,
to the peole that have
let's say $250,000 and more,
who actually would take the
bag and give that love,
I think you have a shot of
being stunned by the ROI,
In todays world, so that's
what I would go out and do,
so the answer to your question is,
how do you remarket them or
market to them to go up,
you let them know about it and,
you know five to 15% of
that audiences will grow up,
with you financially or aspirationally,
but I think you have
to go out and find out,
and find and hunt the 85%
of the rest of the audience.
Just want to take a couple of minutes
before I go in to the question of the day
and give some love to the
people that have consistently
commenting on the show,
which means a ton to me
I thought it was an appropriate time,
not asking for the lurkers to come out
though this would be a phenomenal episode
to leave a comment in the questions
or the comment section
on the YouTube, lurkers
and the ones that are
listening on the podcast,
so let's start with Chad S
really appreciate you, brother.
You're consistent, you're driving it
I'm seeing you, feeling you, thank you.
Roberto, I think you've been
completely on your offense
not only, are you responding consistently
to the question of the day but your
engagement within the Vayner community,
your insanity of intensity
is appreciated,
and we have much love for you Roberto.
Here at the #AskGaryVee show.
Ruth, you've been with me long
before the #AskGaryVee Show
as somebody, you know its funny like
a lot of people by the way
have been telling me to change
my icon on twitter, and one
of the reasons I don't want to
is 'cause Ruth your has
been very consistent
to its visual right
like I know who is there
I see you in all my streams.
I really appriciate your commenting
you have always been a lot of grace
and class to the comment section
much mucho love to you.
Thomas I love you holding
down the youth culture
for the VaynerNation
doing a great a job,
really tight and consistent
with your comments
and, we really just appreciate you, man.
I'm really look, I'm
really really flattered
by the people are consistently commenting,
I think it brings so much
as a matter of fact side question day
how many of you actually
read the comments,
because you getting so much value there
so, Thomas you are a big
part of that I appriciate it.
Victoria J, I don't even know
what it is really about you
but, every time I see
your comments I smile.
Seen them super consistently.
I really appreciate it.
You run the gambit of like
just off the cuff stuff
and really hard-core answers,
I appreciate that as
somebody who loves the
off the cuff stuff as well and so
I really, really, really appreciate you.
All of you, all five of
you, I really appreciate.
There's many more, many
of you Doc and Chef,
you've gotten your love as well
but I am seriously interested.
You know, honestly, and
I did this with Wine Library TV
and I don't want to bull (bleep) you
I am a feedback animal.
I'm a feedback animal.
That's just what it is, like
without the comment section
without the question,
the Instagram questions
are not coming as fast
as I'd like, so you know,
let's link that up.
Without that, without the twitter hashtags
it phases away from me, so
like look if you're listening,
if you're driving to work right now
or working out listening to the podcast,
or if you're watching which is very easy
'cause you are on your phone
or your laptop or iPad right now,
I need more comments
in the comment section.
It's just simple as that.
And the people that have
been doing it for me,
as a matter of fact
that should be the statement for today
all of you should go in and thank
your favorite one of those five people
because it's those people that are,
guys, I will quit this show,
in your face in four seconds
I'm plenty fuckin' busy.
I will quit this show.
You want me to do it, feed me.
I need the fuel and
that's the interaction
that's the engagement.
Question of the day
How do you consume this show?
This, like this
like you know, TV, OTT, like iPad?
I need the answer, curious.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
- [India] What do you mainly
focus on top line revenue
is it because you care more
about staying relevant
and having attention because
you can cash in on that
for more sales?
Oh, are you filming me?
Oh, great.
Well, I would have been better prepared.
- Put that at the end, beep
and it's not me this time.